[Musik]
diese reise ist eine spurensuche
cascada die hochburg der buren in china
der chinesische staat soll sie massiv
unterdrücken peking dementiert das
vehement die polizei in kaschgar steht
an jeder ecke wir werden diesmal nicht
wie frühere male am filmen gehindert
oder offen verfolgt aber die staatsmacht
ist allgegenwärtig wenn man die straße
entlang geht dann merkt man ziemlich
schnell dass überall überwachungskameras
sind wie zb diese was interessant ist
bisher bei unserer reise in gent dass
wir nicht von der polizei direkt
konfrontiert werden sondern von der
ferne sehr engmaschig überwacht werden
erster stopp die berühmte aetka moschee
wir treffen dort auf frau bing chen sie
ist han chinesen die mächtigste und
größte ethnische gruppe in china
sie denkt wie viele ihrer landsleute
glaubt nicht dass china die muslime
systematisch verfolgt was die menschen
hier sagen widerspricht den
ausländischen berichten die vorwürfe
stimmen nicht sagen sie den ausländern
dass es uns gut geht die alten männer
sitzen vor der moschee ein friedliches
bild das wir aus unzähligen berichten
des chinesischen staatsfernsehens kennen
wir treffen drei algerische mädchen fast
beiläufig erzählen sie uns von
umerziehungslager
ohne das wort in den mund zu nehmen um
sie zu schützen machen wie ihre
gesichter unkenntlich
manche leute sind im taxi was ist das
praxis
es ist ein ort zum lernen viele menschen
sind dort deswegen sagen manche uiguren
dass sie nicht frei sind von einigen von
uns wurden papa und mama dorthin
gebracht kennt ihr einige persönlich ja
mein vater ist dort und ihr vater ist
auch dort meiner seit zwei jahren ihr
vater schon seit vier jahren
wisst ihr wenn sie zurückkommen
das wissen wir nichts wir haben keine
mitteilung bekommen
wir können nur darauf warten islamisten
haben in den letzten jahren immer wieder
anschläge in der provinz verübt dabei
starben mehr als 450 han chinesen
deshalb stehen muslime in deutschland
unter generalverdacht und werden
weggesperrt aus sicht der chinesischen
regierung sind die uiguren und
muslimische minderheiten ein unruheherd
dem sie nur mit systematischer
depression her werden kann das hat zum
einen religiös beziehungsweise
extremistische gründe die verbindung die
man dort festgestellt hat zur mittleren
osten
zum anderen hat das politische gründe
durch die autonomie bzw unabhängig
forderungen wird die herrschaft der
kommunistischen partei in frage gestellt
das hat aber auch kriminelle gründe die
unruhe anschläge gewalt anschläge die
wir in china gesehen haben dass alles
rechtfertigt aber aus meiner sicht nicht
eine systematische repression einer
ganzen volksgruppe die systematik ist
aus meiner sicht das entscheiden es geht
wirklich um volksgruppen um ethnische
minderheiten die in ihrer identität
gebrochen werden soll
in johns mehr als 380 lager geben
dies hat ein australischer think tank
anhand von satellitenbildern
dokumentiert experten sprechen von einer
million menschen die muslimischen
minderheiten angehören die china in den
letzten jahren interniert haben soll
ehemalige insassen berichten von folter
und zwangsarbeit die usa werfen peking
völkermord vor und beschließen wie die
eu sanktionen
in nahezu jedem dorf in nahezu jeder
schulklasse in nahezu jeder
nachbarschaft es eben hinweise darauf
gibt dass menschen oftmals auch ohne
triftigen grund oder mit berufung auf
da gibt es extremistische tendenzen in
diese lager geschickt werden wir nehmen
uns ein taxi wollen zu einem möglichen
umerziehungslager fahren etwa 20 minuten
außerhalb von kaschgar im netz findet
man viele satelliten aufnahmen wo man
arbeitslager und umerziehungslager
erkennen kann hier zu diesem roten punkt
wollen wir und dann sieht man hier die
quasi lager artige anlage unser fahrer
bekommt plötzlich einen anruf wird
nervös wahrscheinlich hat die polizei
sich bei seinem chef gemeldet er soll
die ausländer loswerden wir haben keine
wahl wir müssen aussteigen
es sind noch drei kilometer bis zum
lager die gehen wir zu fuß
wir erreichen den gebäudekomplex in dem
sich ein umerziehungslager befinden soll
satellitenaufnahmen zeigen dass 2017 die
anlage umgebaut wurde von außen können
wir nicht viel erkennen das gelände ist
gesichert wie ein gefängnis im hinteren
teil soll sich das lager befinden wir
versuchen näher ran zu kommen um einen
blick nach innen zu werfen
offiziell ist das hier eine parteischule
aber es gibt auch eine menge hinweise
dass dies ein umerziehungslager ist wir
haben drinnen die beiden wachtürme
gesehen wir sehen diese riesige mauer
hier die das gelände einrahmt und den
stacheldrahtzaun drumherum
also das ist sehr stark gesichert zurück
nach kafka gerade einmal ein paar
kilometer entfernt vom umerziehungslager
ist die renovierte altstadt ein
ungarisches disneyland jeden morgen um 9
uhr 30 beginnt in kaschgar die
offizielle völkerverständigung chinesen
aus dem ganzen land kommen in bussen
vorgefahren um die traditionellen tänze
der uiguren zu bestaunen
die han chinesen treffen auf die
muslimische minderheit diese bilder sind
im sinne der chinesischen
staatspropaganda nach klasse kombi ist
ein wunsch von mir gewesen wir lieben
die tänzer vom sind sehr
seit zwei jahren fasziniert von die
uigurische kultur
sie hat sich die tracht angezogen und
die schritte eingeübt im richtigen leben
ist die staatsbeamten gewesen
im kasch gas altstadt scheinen die lager
endlos weit weg wir wollen die schöne
landschaft um unseren vater land
genießen und die kultur und die
geschichte von südchina erleben
der chinesische staat will der welt
zeigen wie er sich um die uigurische
kultur kümmert er hat knapp eine
milliarde euro in die sanierung der
altstadt investiert
es ist wie so oft in diesem land wer
gehorcht dem versprechen die machthaber
ein gutes leben viel erzählen uns es
gehen auch besser als früher
alle lebensbereiche seien besser
geworden sagte zum beispiel die bildung
es gebe eine schulpflicht und die schule
sei kostenlos in der altstadt gibt es
auch viele traditionelle uigurische
restaurants hier hat man das gefühl die
figuren bleiben unter sich
es wird kaum chinesisch gesprochen viele
beherrschen diese sprache nicht
einige sagen uns ohne chinesisch kann
man nicht wirklich in china erfolgreich
sein
ich hab chinesisch in der schule gelernt
ist es wichtig die sprache zu können
ja wir brauchen wir am arbeitsplatz oder
wann wir etwas erledigen wohl dafür ist
wichtig
als wir dann noch nach dem zusammenleben
der hand chinesen mit den uiguren fragen
wird sie nervös und stoppt das interview
es ist zeit ich muss zur arbeit gehen
viele menschen haben angst etwas
falsches zu sagen sie wissen dass sie
die staatsmacht ständig beobachtet wir
haben das immer wieder erlebt
wer das ausmaß der unterdrückung
begreifen will muss zum beispiel mit und
uhren wie mammut hahn abdrehen reden das
schicksal seiner familie ist dramatisch
und steht wohl für die tragödie seines
volkes
er war mit seiner frau und den beiden
kindern nach australien ausgewandert
seine frau war im musste aber wegen
ihres reisepasses mit den kindern nach
kashgar zurückfahren
die polizei nahm dort den pass ab sie
verdächtigten sie eine islamistin zu
sein das war 2017
das chinesische außenministerium hat in
einem schwammigen statement einer
pressekonferenz erklärt dass meine frau
zu neun jahren gefängnis wegen der
sogenannten anstacheln zum ethnischen
hass angaben keine weiteren details oder
legten bürgen welche beweise fast alles
blieb völlig unklar
er hat seit vier jahren keinen kontakt
zu seiner frau oder seinen kindern
gehabt nur ein paar kleine videoclips
bekam er zugespielt
er hofft dass die westlichen demokratien
das schicksal seiner familie und der
uiguren nicht vergessen und den druck
auf china erhöhen die usa und andere
westliche länder haben sanktionen gegen
einzelne verantwortliche verhängen aber
diese haben größtenteils nur einen
symbolischen charakter
deshalb ignoriert china sie und hat
ihrerseits sanktionen verhängt
wirklicher druck würde entstehen durch
wirksame wirtschaftssanktionen zb den
import von produkten aus china im großen
ausmaß zu untersagen
er wird nicht aufgeben für seine familie
zu kämpfen aber die hoffnung schwindet
manchmal schaffe ich es optimistisch in
die zukunft zu blicken und hoffe dass es
vielleicht doch ein wiedersehen mit
meiner familie gibt aber die realität
lässt mich verzweifeln wenn ich an die
zukunft denke den mädchen die wir vor
der moschee getroffen haben geht es
ihnen
auch sie wachsen ohne eltern auf sie
wissen nicht wann sie sie wiedersehen
für viele chorische kinder eine traurige
normalität
kennt ihr viele kinder in eurer schule
deren eltern weg gebracht wurden
90 prozent der kinder in meiner klasse
geht dass wir uns manchmal will ich dass
ich vermisse mein vater ich bin sehr
traurig spurensuche in jamaica eine
chinesische stadt in der die staatsmacht
die muslime verfolgt in lager sperrt und
viele kinder ohne ihre eltern aufwachsen
lässt
[Musik]